the fifth installment of the series
Pirates of the Caribbean worship
caribbean dead men tell no tales is in
theaters on Friday May 26th and one of
the stars have said film is sitting to
my right
also brilliantly playing Albert Einstein
and the nat geo series genius which is
on Tuesdays at 9:00 Eastern Time the
Emmy Tony and Academy award-winning
actor Geoffrey Rush here in the
Richardson show studio hello sir thanks
for being here
Triple Crown you were the tradition I
probably think I'm talking about the
Kentucky the Kentucky Derby yes the
other one Belmont ozobot yes praedyth
the Preakness is coming on Saturday well
if you were on tomorrow show we would
have one of the premier sports
handicappers of his generation a
gentleman named Hank Goldberg from down
in South Florida we would invite you to
be part of our of our wagering if you
were on tomorrow show and it's welcome
to you now as well I'm sure all of the
tests you don't follow the term now I
should you know this is we have the
Melbourne Cup in in us very right kind
of the big we boast it's the biggest in
the southern hemisphere anything that's
big in the southern hemisphere did you
ever watch Australian rules football
ever follow whatever do any tight would
let at all I when I've had a difficult
time with sports since I was about nine
hmm why is that
well I grew up in Brisbane and the the
game up there was the big game of this
rugby league yes it's brutal and when I
was in grade four grade five maybe it
was kind of compulsory that you had to
go into a team yes so I went I'll give
it a shot
you know yes and I was in the under four
stone seven so that's about 70 pounds I
was a skinny kid and I went out there
and I saw all these grade five boys I
reckon they're over four stone seven
there's no way they were racing towards
me and I just turned and ran long away
and I've been running over well I think
it's worked out for you but in my
situation I realized that I could not
the curveball and baseball as well as
others or a jump shot in basketball as
well as others and decided to talk about
it instead of you hang it that's what I
will find a niche I actually we've got a
sports writer on the Nobin age who's I
think the greatest journalist in the
country I don't even got on to him by
accident because he gets front-page
coverage not just in the sports pages at
the back he's like his prose is
somewhere between Hemingway and Greek
drama he is a brilliant radical Greg
bone okay and I remember when the
Australian Open was on one of the early
seeds was Federer up against this bright
young brash boy called Tomich mhm and
Greg bombs article was the greatest read
about sport you know you went this what
the newspaper people call it's a good
read yes and so that's the sort of
stutter his gift and I've expressed my
fandom to him publicly as often as I can
because sometimes the press get a bit
lazy
mm-hmm are you serious come on now
Geoffrey don't say that now but I saw I
was going to ask you about the whole
Australian rules football the guys in
the suits who make the make the you know
make the arm movement for points and
stuff like yeah it a spectacular game to
what my son follows it and I love
watching with him and I love the action
replays in Australian rules are
spectacular because these guys they
climb up each other yes like it's like a
leopard going up an elephant's leg they
get right up and take the mark and
there's no padding or anything like that
seated and we you know we in the
National Football League we pad up we
put helmets on not these yet on and they
were convinced no that's why you turned
around and ran I've got Geoffrey Rush
here in the Rich Eisen show studio so is
it Pirates of the Caribbean or Pirates
of the Caribbean Geoffrey we're not
going Caribbean Lynn's oh okay well how
you guys out of the line side moment
there I okay I just met these boys
before mm-hmm the track Chris Chris and
I went a equals mc-squared
oh my god straight off the top Wow
how's that we've ever had Aizen have a
member people's names you notice under
patent we are e M equals M and then C
squared
you know what if I don't think that the
three of them combined or squared is
equal to me like you're lying
what do i what do i do on that front
then the equations completely ruined
what has it been like playing Einstein
what did you learn about him that read
or didn't know a lot most of them 95% of
the stuff that's actually in the details
of this 10-part drama series I knew
nothing I was four when he died in 1955
so I know him as a pop cultural icon and
you know he was in his era as famous as
Charlie Chaplin kind of but he was a
theoretical physicist and to be a
household name right as a cosmological
mathematician is just amazing you know
but in his more personal life this is
what the series goes into yes it deals
with his two marriages which you know
who were both unfortunate in some
degrees and they were he'd like what was
the phrase usually like he's Gettysburg
it was shocking to me to see how we're
getting busy always that's not like
there yeah yes I was very busy it was it
was great it was known as an era big
libido he was a great lover and women
were very big part of his life yeah I
wouldn't I would never you know put that
two and two together again something
about the hair could've been well look
you know with me I you know I'm going
the other direction on that front
but you know it's interesting as well of
the films that you you've been in and
that I've been such a big fan of before
we talked about the Pirates movie Munich
you were part of a film that was
chronicling of a very obviously
important moment in the world of sports
in new zone and a cross-section what was
that like for you to be on the set with
Spielberg for a movie it was fantastic
because Tony Kushner a kind of wrote a
very complex
portrait of the whole event without kind
of demonizing one side of the other but
trying to look at really what happens it
was a pretty devastating attack at the
72 olympics you know and I'd known
Steven Spielberg a little bit socially
and everything and he he was such a
master and you know him you know people
like Daniel Craig was in it and Myles he
made Eric Bana it was a very very good
team
ciarán hinds good strong actors Geoffrey
Rush here and the Rich Eisen show when
you first got the script for Shakespeare
in Love what did you think when you saw
that script and you got it and I was
sitting in my agents office in Sydney
and I'm a huge Tom Stoppard fan and he
had done a lot of work on the second
kind of drafting of it and I got to like
page five first scene and I looked up at
my agent I said I have to be in this the
dialogue was just so smart and so good
and suddenly you're on the set of a
movie that did you know at the time that
you had some sort of I think we lost
roadworthiness little thought it was
going to be a small Bijou our house kind
of experience but Harvey Weinstein kind
of turned it into a date movie and it
you know it's broke the magic hundred
million dollar mark and all that stuff
and it was it was great
Jeffrey Russia Iran the Rich Eisen show
and I thought the Pirates movies were
supposed to stop after 3:00 here we are
on 5:00 I mean what would what why is
this still going on what what do you the
writer piece of a popularities kept
coming up with more adventures I think
you know Jerry Bruckheimer is a very
creative producer he doesn't churn him
out year after year he waits until he
thinks he's got better stories more
interesting new characters and I have to
admit with this v it's gonna blow
everyone's socks off with the
really groundbreaking CGI visual effects
in it something else yeah I mean we
showed the clip review with Javier
Bardem and in the television only
segment is his hair looks like it's
going through some sort of matrix
okay yeah that is all done in
post-production because he's come up
from under the sea I mean Xavier sort of
plays it he's a half man/half brawn and
he had this amazing prosthetic makeup on
to make him look like it was a
crustacean
but in post they then made his hair look
like it's constantly underwater even
when he's out in the air and it's really
almost poetic
and what is your number Geoffrey Russia
what is your guilty pleasure movie that
we would be shocked that Geoffrey Rush
loves this movie can't get enough of it
if you're watching it on television you
drop the remote what what would that it
not mine any other any movie of BS not
yours any movie that I remember really
loving Jennifer Lopez in you turn there
I've said it
you you got that off your chest I got it
off my chest
yeah you like that really in real yeah
what do you like about it uh it was just
good to watch my favorite film of all
time a silent film town and Charlie
Chaplin city lights I recommend everyone
sees it well I mean you know here in the
21st century recommending a silent movie
might fall with a little bit of a thud
but why so uh just great storytelling
gags that still work I've seen it with
big houses and in retro cinemas and
stuff and it's great to hear laughs that
are 86 years old or 80 seven years off
sure so the headline if you if you don't
mind because I know what you said about
the media is Geoffrey Rush loves
Jennifer Lopez and Charlie Chaplin is
that the headline of this conversation
they like that we can go with that and
is there is there I'm hearing a rumor
that Paul McCartney is involved with
this yeah film that you're in right now
well you know this so there's always
been a little bit
kind of flavor of having Keith Richards
in because johnny was really inspired by
the kind of the rockers of the 60s on
you was first looking at how to create
Jack Sparrow and then I think he decided
why don't we get him in and he can play
my dad and then I don't think keith was
available on this shoot so they brought
Paul McCartney and there's one of
Johnny's uncles and then there you
haven't anything can we tell where's oh
yeah you need to be ok you can
understand yeah yeah yeah he's in that's
great well in drag but I think I've
heard he's a pretty good singer we need
to get you a Grammy Jeffrey Wright
whatever how can we get you a Grammy to
content to complete the the Emmy Grammy
Oscar Tony honey loss would ya know what
I'm quite happy being at oh I miss hear
you're at oh yeah you got big toe okay
alright well the big toe Geoffrey Rush
can be seen in Pirates of the Caribbean
dead men tell no tales coming up next
Friday and then an ingenious the Nat Geo
series about Albert Einstein Tuesdays at
9:00 Eastern Time thank you so much for
coming on sir this has been my pleasure
thank you thanks to the equation like it
e equals M and then C squared it's
pretty good
mind blown pretty good Geoffrey Rush
here on the Rich Eisen show is good
so Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on radio stations across the
country and audience if you liked that
video be sure to download our app and
I'll be sure to help the NFL figure out
what it catches